a smartphone and an additional
wide-angle lens that's all Sebastian
Linda needs for his videos he also edits
the clips on his device doing some
fine-tuning and adding a few special
effects then the filmmaker from dresden
uploads his clips onto Instagram he uses
the videos to keep fans up to date about
his upcoming project the finishing
spending with this kind of you it's an
exciting opportunity but I'm still going
to work on bigger projects yeah camacho
these clips can go viral a cool shot can
get a couple hundred thousand views but
i prefer telling stories spending more
time on of them so they have a more
lasting impacts all submission affect
his half-hour documentary the journey of
the beast is a good example for that
film Sebastian Linda accompanied 10 pro
skaters on a journey through Indonesia
the film won Germany's 2015 web video
prize in the best camera category
Sebastian originally uploaded the clip
on Vimeo that way users could access it
on demand with improved transfer rates
nowadays even high res films can be
uploaded at speed online streaming
platforms are becoming increasingly
diverse for pay services like Amazon
Prime instant video and Netflix offer
popular TV series and feature-length
films
YouTube is also adapting to new consumer
behavior according to youtube content
manager Ben mokou and Wilson the
platform is increasingly focusing on
long-form content also people thought it
was all about short form content as as
YouTube emerged but actually people like
bikes are showing that you can get
really really strong viewing figures for
30 55-minute pieces of high quality
company people are increasingly
producing and consuming videos on mobile
devices Digital expert Richard gutiar
says the trend set to continue its
landing bond is a mobile and so now
mobile networks were too weak to
transfer video properly was inviting
gazania always get that bar or that
small turning wheel Kenneth out soon
gave food but the new g5 mobile network
generation will offer transfer rates
that are faster than any fiber optic
cable we have today sees glass cause I
covered us a moment in the etiquette
book at this the new mobile network
standard will be available in about five
years offering speeds of six gigabits
per second hi res videos will download
in seconds the shift to mobile viewing
is also creating new platforms the vine
app focuses on six second loops and stop
motion tricks the snapchat messenger
service focuses on vertical videos
Sebastian Linda appreciates the
diversity that's available today
irrelevance materialism it's becoming
more relevant because more people are
online more people have PCs and
smartphones that constraint apps keep
getting better so it'll keep developing
by 10 begin Sebastian is still making
videos for Instagram as well as working
on his long format project
once he's completed his next film it too
will premiere on line shift says go with
the flow